We Begin the day with the current U.S
president and the man who wants to have
his job again
President Joe Biden has called the
results of Tuesday's midterm elections
good for democracy with Democrats
holding on to more seats in Congress
than they had expected the next two
years of the Biden Administration are
looking better than many expected
Democrats had a strong night
and we lost fewer seats in the House of
Representatives than any Democratic
President's first midterm election the
last 40 years
and we had the best midterm for
Governors since 1986. I'm prepared to
work in my Republican colleagues
the American people have made clear I
think that they expect Republicans to be
prepared to work with me as well
as the president there sounding
bipartisan a positive spin on those
results it all sounds good unless you
are the Republicans who ran for congress
with Donald Trump's endorsement those
candidates of course lost it may be a
time for soul searching for the GOP and
for Donald Trump as well in just the
last 24 hours more and more Republicans
have gone public with a call for change
meaning they want a presidential
candidate in 2024 who will win and whose
name will not be Donald Trump is Trump's
bid for the White House is it over
before it even begins again
well my first guest tonight he knows a
thing or two about the White House he's
a former white house inside a Richard
painter was the chief ethics lawyer for
President George W bush he's now a
professor of corporate law at the
University of Minnesota
Professor painter it's good to have you
with us again your politics is changing
all the time in the United States I want
to start today by showing our viewers
the front page of the New York Post
today I don't know if you've seen it but
I'll describe it here it shows Donald
Trump as Humpty Dumpty sitting on a wall
and it reads Dawn who couldn't build a
wall had a great fall can all the gop's
men put the party back together again
now we have to remind ourselves the New
York Post that's a Rupert Murdoch
newspaper
does this tell you that the Republican
party is now done with Donald Trump
well we don't know uh we'll see what
happens and whether Donald Trump
declares for the presidency and what the
reaction is uh from leading Republicans
we do know that uh Governor DeSantis of
Florida had a very very good night on
Tuesday night winning his uh re-election
as Governor there by blowout this is a
state that of course was very very hotly
contested between Democrats and
Republicans uh when George W bush became
president but is now Republican
dominated uh so descent is certainly uh
be a threat to Donald Trump if Governor
DeSantis decides to run for president
the Republicans though on Tuesday night
around the country uh had three problems
one of them is Donald Trump in the
baggage of Donald Trump Americans are
tired of him and particularly uh most
Americans particularly swing voters are
very upset about the way Donald Trump uh
refused to conceive defeat in 2020 and
the Insurrection of January 6 and his
contribution to that uh Donald Trump is
a lot of baggage for the Republican
Party second of course was the abortion
issue which has motivated a lot of
Voters particularly Women Voters in the
suburbs not to support the Republican
party at all now getting rid of Donald
Trump won't solve that problem unless
the Republican Party takes a more
moderate stance on abortion rights and
then the third problem was the body
candidates there were a number of
candidates particularly those who were
pushed and promoted in primaries by
Donald Trump who were inferior
candidates who did very very poorly uh
and uh Dr Oz in Pennsylvania was one of
them the Republicans had had opportunity
to nominate someone who would have been
a very staunch conservative but more
traditional Republican and they might
have won that seat uh and they didn't a
seat that was Republican has now gone
over to the Democrats in Pennsylvania
would you say that Professor painter
that by listening to you it sounds like
you think that a trump endorsement has
now become toxic at the ballot box is
that what the midterms are telling us
well Trump endorsement apparently worked
very well in primaries uh in Republican
primaries where only the most die-hard
Republicans show up but in the general
election the Trump endorsement is very
toxic because swing voters those who
sometimes vote Democrats sometimes vote
Republican uh will have no respect uh
for uh Donald Trump's approach to
elections I mean Donald Trump lost by
eight million votes in 2020 and it
wasn't even close it was not a bush
versus Gore situation like what we had
in year 2000 22 years ago and uh the way
Donald Trump handled that being a sore
loser and not only that but instigating
violence and engaging in other seditious
activity that was probably criminal and
that he may get indicted for I think he
should get invited for that is a very
big turnoff for the vast majority of the
American people but do you still think
the professor painter is he going to go
ahead and announce his candidacy
well he may and uh whether or not he
thinks he can win
um he may announce his candidacy because
he's focused only on himself and his own
ego he also may think that announcing
his candidacy will slow down the
Department of Justice investigation and
potential indictment of President Trump
in connection with in particular uh the
Insurrection of January 6 in the attempt
to overthrow the United States
government I mean there is enormous
amounts of evidence that has been made
public now about his role in trying to
do anything he could to stay in power uh
basically a self-cool uh which has
happened to many democracies uh where
someone who's in power wants to stay in
power and will reject Democratic
elections and we simply can't tolerate
that in the United States but he may
want to declare uh his candidacy so the
Department of Justice thinks oh gee now
it might be a political conflict of
interest for us to indict him because
he's now a candidate we have to appoint
a special counsel and we have to delay
this another six months or a year uh and
I think that would be a mistake for the
Department of Justice if they haven't
died in there but they haven't indicted
him the uh Professor painter and that's
what makes me wonder if maybe he's
thinking that this attorney general Mary
Garland is not going to take action
against a former president and therefore
of course yeah it makes sense for him to
declare his candidacy and he can just
run down the clock I mean is do you
think that the justice department is
going to to change course now that the
midterms are open over
well they certainly wouldn't have been
died immediately before then uh the
midterms so if they're going to indict
him they would indict him uh after the
midterms I believe the evidence is
overwhelming they probably want to let
the January 6 committee uh finish up
with its hearings a lot of the evidence
has been exposed there I wrote not bad
in the Washington Post with Professor
Claire Finkelstein at the University of
Pennsylvania we laid out the case for
Dottie Donald Trump for criminal
sedition
um in connection with his conduct after
the election he committed other crimes
and offices well I think the Attorney
General needs to get going uh we cannot
have anyone who is above the law not a
president not a former president if we
want to keep our representative
democracy
Professor Richard painter as always Mr
painter we appreciate your time and your
insights always appreciate it thank you
thank you very much for having me
[Music]
following the midterms the Biden
Administration has been quick to assure
Ukraine that it will be business as
usual the weapons and the aid will
continue flowing whatever the outcome
the White House brushing off concerns
that a republican-controlled House of
Representatives in Congress could
perhaps pull the plug on assistance for
Kiev in the war with Russia here's the
president's Special Assistant
our expectation is that the the outcome
of the midterm elections is not going to
impact U.S policy towards Ukraine in the
least there's strong bipartisan support
for all the actions we've taken to
support the Ukrainian people in
government and hold Russia accountable
so no we don't expect any major changes
how do the U.S midterm elections look
from this side of the Atlantic what is
the picture of American democracy as
seen from here in Berlin joining me here
at the big table is mentine hot Verity a
member of the German Parliament with the
social Democrats party that's the SPD
he's also Deputy chairman of the German
U.S parliamentary friendship group Mr
huckford it's good to have you back it's
good to see you again after after this
long pandemic what do you see when you
look towards the U.S at the moment
we we see all the problems but tonight
we're just feel relieved um that things
didn't go really bad so um
better than yesterday what would what
would have been from from Berlin's
perspective what would have been a worst
case scenario
starting with the worst case scenario
okay yeah but the worst case would have
been that election deniers basically
people that want that are willing to
blow up the Democracy the democratic
system of the United States would get
into very important offices where they
can do it actually and the American
voter we're not in favor of this idea so
mostly not and uh that feels a little
better than yesterday
do you think most German lawmakers would
say the best case scenario would have
been a sweeping democratic
victory for congress okay probably at
this time the Democratic party we feel a
little closer to the Democratic party
for several reasons because of the Trump
experience of course but if you look at
Republican governor of Georgia so he
resisted the the call for free election
now so no it's a question of value it's
not a question of left and right it's
not a question of Republican Democratic
it's a question of whether you stand for
the Republic right yeah yeah and I know
you spent also a lot of time in the U.S
you know a lot of congressmen
congresswomen
how do they explain to you this
incredible polarization of politics in
America
most would describe it as a process that
has been going on for a long longer time
now not only since the election of
Donald Trump but before that
um it has a lot to do with with money
with the two-party system of course
um
it has to do with a frustration about
the government generally the government
in Washington
you remember that Sam Washington is
broken the Tea Party Movement back in
the day it's a lot of things are just
accumulating now to this personal of the
Republican party and of course Mr Trump
was the most important symbol to it and
we will see
um whether it's just him or more to that
movement
um I believe there's more to trumpism
than just Mr Trump so we will have to
deal with it in the future we've heard
this week from several commentators here
in Germany that the the the actual the
polarization or the break in the
breaking down of politics in America
began in 2000 with Al Gore not becoming
president and we've heard this week time
and time again almost lamenting if Gore
had become president the world would be
very different climate change would be a
lot further is there is there that type
of
um yeah wishing that things could have
been different among
German lawmakers when you're talking
about the U.S no we are not wishing for
governments in other countries uh and
not in the United States as well but uh
but the United States the most important
country in the world it's our most
important Ally outside Europe
um the United States brought us
democracy so we are thankful for that
forever
um but we are really just afraid
seriously afraid of of the Democracy in
the United States so it's not too much a
matter of whether Democratic candidate
wins or a republican uh we're probably
I'm in Social Democrats so you can think
of it yeah I find uh more sympathy for
but
um no the the important the important
issue is that institutional values of
balance of power
as we say yeah the rule of law yeah rule
of law so so this is uh this is what
it's taken this makes us feel all
uncomfortable and this is not related to
Party politics
a considerable number of Republicans who
were elected yesterday to Congress
Republicans are election deniers I mean
you even have some who say that Joe
Biden is not the legitimate U.S
president
um how do you as a member of parliament
how do you imagine working together with
them when you go over to Washington you
go over all the time how do you sit down
and talk to them eye to eye and find
Common Ground if they're representative
of that country of their state of their
voting district of their constituency
that's what they are but then it's one
one value less we share right so it is a
problem it is a problem not only for the
United States itself but also for us and
for the relationship but you know there
are other countries around in the world
we don't share all the values but do you
really believe Mr huntvidi that these
election denials do they really
represent a majority of the people in
the districts where they come from or
are they through the primary system
through gerrymandering of voting
districts are they the results of
extreme politics that's gotten through
the system well I I would say after the
Trump election we all know about the
deficits of the of the voting system of
the United States at this point so we're
representing more people at the
Democratic value obviously there are a
lot of cases where it's not the case
right so uh without the gerrymandering
and all the other issues you mentioned
um but at this point this is what we
have in the United States right yes we
have to accept that it's unfair it's not
a representation is is an issue
um but we who are we outside the United
States to judge that it is the business
of the United States and you know you
know the history of Germany so
um other people have also issues uh so
uh I wish the best for the United States
for the people of the United States but
also of course for the world global
order because we need the country
Joe Biden versus Donald Trump in 2024
many say that that is where we are
headed
what goes through your mind as a German
lawmaker the prospect that in 2024 you
could have
again Donald Trump as U.S president long
way to go so we will see now who's going
to be Canada for the Republican party as
I understood the re-election results in
the State of Florida there might be an
issue another next month but maybe
tomorrow who's going to be candidate for
the Republicans and we see what the
debate goes and and with the Democratic
party as well so it's too early to say
that but what we do know is no matter
who's going to represent what party
trumpism this frustration with a
representation and democracy generally
will be an issue in the United States so
we should be just calling out for those
people that try to make the life of the
people better in the United States and
hope for the best for Democratic Values
you know this is uh the country as I
said brought democracy to our country
um so there is there's still a lot of
trust left that they will they will do
it it's good to hear Mr stock video as
always we appreciate your time
appreciate you coming in it's good to
see you again thank you thank you
hi I'm Diane macedo today on ABC News
live we want to get right to our top
story Americans are casting their final
votes on this election day in one of the
most consequential midterms in decades
votes are being counted in The crucial
midterm elections in the United States
see me just after 8 PM there where you
are this is the hour when the first
flood of results is expected what should
we be preparing for but I just want to
step back again and just look at this
map right that's not a red wave that's
nothing like a Red Wave the Republican
party needs to do a really deep
introspection look in the mirror right
now because this is this is an absolute
disaster for the Republican party and we
need to turn back so the three big
losers again Donald yeah
they all begin with the letter D Dobbs
right
and election deniers
and that is how we in the news media the
mainstream media if you will reported
the U.S midterms on Tuesday tonight we
want to ask did journalists get the
story right and to discuss that I'm
happy to welcome tonight
Sargon she's Deputy opinion editor at
Newsweek she is also the author of the
book bad news how woke media is
undermining democracy it is a sobering
assessment of what happens when
journalism in the U.S went from a
blue-collar trade to a profession of the
elites
but it's good to have you with us so let
me just start by asking you how have the
news media reported the story of the
midterm elections in America
uh thank you so much for having me uh
it's great to be here with you so yeah I
mean you know we got this wrong uh I got
this wrong a lot of us were looking at
the polling and we were listening to
voters and talking to voters and one got
the sense that there was going to be a
huge red wave that voters were very
upset about the economy and that the
Democrats had failed to coalesce around
a singular message on the economy and
how they were going to make things
better for voters
um you had a lot of Voters talking about
crime and uh 2 million illegal
immigrants crossing the border you know
that the breakdown of the rule of law
and there was really this sense that
they were going to really rebuke the
president's party which is very normal
by the way for a midterm election and
that just didn't happen um you know the
Senate is leaning to towards the
Democrats the houses may be a little bit
leaning towards the Republicans they
might take the majority but in a very
small way
you know after the elections in 2018 and
2020 in the U.S we talked with a lot of
upholsterers such as yougov as well as
Gallup and they admitted that the
reliability of polling now has to be put
into question because the traditional
method of interviewing people on the
telephone
sometimes it's become almost impossible
as a result we here we've been very
hesitant to rely on polling numbers
leading up to the midterm elections of
the U.S that was not the case among U.S
networks and and cable news for example
why do you think that was why rely on
data that that is you know is suspect
that's a really great question
um you know we got to fill the time
somehow right now but I mean seriously I
I do think that um you know um we have
in this country we don't it looks like a
political divide but it's not it's
really a class divide we have two
parties that by and large cater to the
elites of either side and then we have
mass mass amounts of working class and
middle class Americans who really rarely
get to have their say and our media as I
write in my book is so deeply committed
now to the voices of the elites that
rather than going out and actually
talking to voters
um you know media characters pundits
journalists just like politicians would
rather sit there and look at numbers and
then prognosticate about them so I think
it's that sort of Disconnect between the
media which is really part of the elites
today and then you know the masses of
Americans who don't get to have their
say well let me ask you about about this
this term Elites I mean journalists are
we are like it or not we're Gatekeepers
even with with the internet and with
citizen journalists we're still
Gatekeepers and that that gives you a
amount of power also Authority great
responsibility so is it it's not
necessarily a negative thing is it
I think if your job is to tell the Great
American story you know the first draft
of History to signal to politicians and
people with immense amounts of power
what they should care about I think it's
very bad to live in a way that not only
has elevated you above your fellow
Americans but what has happened as a
result of that is journalists have
developed a lot of contempt for average
Americans and and I think that's very
bad yes I I I I'm sorry yeah I mean I I
mean I I take your point there and I'm
wondering too what about the the role of
journalists as Educators
um reporters I noticed in the run-up to
the midterms were saying non-stop that
um the U.S voters blame the U.S
president on the
um they blame him for inflation they
blame him for the economy but I very I
saw very little attempts at reporting
and educating people about the fact that
the president may have actually very
limited means of stopping inflation
quickly and that that may actually lie
with central banks for example with the
U.S federal reserve we didn't see those
attempts to educate the voters instead
what we saw was reporters just saying
voters blame the president why do you
think reporters dropped the ball there
um honestly I would never ever presume
to think that I should be educating a
single mom working two jobs and
commuting an hour or either way I would
never dream of thinking it's my job to
educate a truck driver who sits in a
truck for 14 hours a day delivering
every morsel of food that you know we
and on the coast put in our mouths I
would never dream of educating a person
who works on a railroad like that that's
just not my job my job is to hear their
concerns and reflect them back to the
rest of the American people and you know
my life is so much easier than working
class Americans it is so much easier
than the the struggles that black
Americans face with crime in in just
exploding in their neighborhoods the
working class struggling to achieve an
American dream that is no longer in
reach I just don't think that that is
our job I do think most people in the
Progressive and liberal media do think
it's their job to tell voters what to
care about but that's why they've lost
credibility well what about the role of
journalists particularly in the United
States to help
support an informed electorate you mean
you want
um you want smart voters going in into
those polling stations and making
informed decisions right do you think
that that responsibility has been
sometimes forgotten in the in the news
media commercialized news media in the
U.S
I have to tell you I have never met a
person who is struggling to make it who
is not deeply informed about what they
who best represents their interests like
that is not something for us to tell
them they know that and the idea that
somehow there's a piece of information
that they're missing that would make
them vote for the party that we and the
elites believe better represent their
interests I've just never bought into
that I I just don't buy that I think
people know what's in their best
interests and and I think the problem
with the media today is that we think we
know what's in their best interest but
they know what's in their best interests
I've got one more minute it's an
excellent conversation look to 2024.
2024 yeah we don't get to do this every
day I mean it's almost a luxury um what
would you what would you hope for the
the coverage leading us to 2024 and the
next presidential election I've got 30
seconds
I have to tell you I think the The
Narrative that America has never been
more polarized is a total myth middle
and working class Americans have never
been more united about the values that
this great nation was founded on it's
people who make money off of trying to
divide us and get power off of it who
are just making up this story about
polarization and I just wish we would
stop and we would actually reflect where
voters are at where Americans are at
yeah building some bridges there baccia
it's good to have you on the show we
appreciate your insights come back and
talk with us I'm sure we're going to
have plenty of reasons to talk in the
future thank you
thank you